Nga khẳng định các biển pháp trường phản đân phương cáo sài gần bốn thầm qua
không gây ra tất cả đồng đáng tệ đồ với nền tình tế, đồng thời cho sang
nước này đã sân hình thành khả năng thích ứng trong một trường hạn chế.
Thông nghề phân ngón điện Kremlin Dimitri Pascope, các có trường phản liên tiếp tử phân tay
dù có phạm vi giận và nhám vình nhiều lĩnh vực như năng lượng ngân hàng hay thương mại
chưa buộc mắt gà và phải trời đổi định hướng.
Chúng kiến đỏ liền mình chỗ A, uống đưa thương qua mười táng có trường phản
và vẫn năng xem xét tập hiện pháp bổ sung.
Các đổi dùng mới có thể báo gồm hạn chế xuất khẩu, hại trên giá sâu thông
và kìm sốt thì thống thành phản cú tế, Mỹ cũng định ngọt khả năng hành động tụi tự
Ngà khẳng định như Việt pham này còn kế ám lực trường lại đối với chính các nền kinh để cho ông
bốn phụ thuận vào năng lượng và thị trường khu vực.
Chúng bất cảnh đó về suy chiều định và giảm thiệu tất cả đồng kế
được xem là thách thức lớn đưa vĩ cả hai bên.